Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
On sent l'odeur de l'ambiance.
Elle est bonne, l’ambiance ce soir.
Ça sent le théâtre.
On va en parler des odeurs.
On respire, on hume, on sent
en permanence par nos narines.
Donc on vit.
À ce propos-là,
j’ai une petite devinette pour vous
ce soir, spécialement pour vous.
Devinez le produit de luxe
qui sent l’urine de cochon.
Réfléchissez un petit peu,
mais si quelquefois en tranches,
dans des plats un petit peu chers.
Vous voyez, la truffe, bien sûr.
Curieusement, elle libère,
elle exhale une odeur, l’androsténone -
c’est un champignon, la truffe, bien sûr -
et la même substance
est secrétée par l’urine de cochon,
l'urine du cochon mâle.
Certains lui trouvent une odeur
animale un peu musquée,
d’autres une odeur un peu plus florale.
Donc on a compris :
les odeurs suscitent des émotions.
Trois types d’émotions et une partie
du cerveau qui interprète ça.
On en parlera après.
Neutre : indifférence.
Plaisir : j’ai envie de continuer à humer.
Ou bien ça pue, c'est repoussant.
La capacité du cerveau,
c’est de transformer cette émotion
en un sentiment :
la joie, le plaisir, l’envie,
la nostalgie, parfois le dégoût,
quelquefois la sensualité,
notamment par l’odeur de jasmin.
Donc, vous voyez, les odeurs
ont un certain pouvoir.
Finalement ces odeurs, elles sont
liées à des mécanismes chimiques.
Mais quand on regarde,
quand on respire,
une odeur, c’est très très volatil.
Donc c’est très peu matériel.
En fait,
les odeurs
sont des minuscules molécules
évanescentes.
Et ces molécules, telles des petites clés,
vont se fixer
sur des récepteurs
à la surface des cellules olfactives.
On a des millions de cellules olfactives
au fin fond des fosses nasales.
Et en réponse à ce signal,
eh bien, chaque cellule,
tel un instrument de musique,
va envoyer sa partition
de notes au cerveau,
sachant qu’on peut assimiler
chaque note de musique
à l’effet d’une molécule
sur son récepteur.
Le cerveau va construire l’harmonie,
l’espèce de bouquet final olfactif
à partir de ces éléments.
Les odeurs,
c’est un sens extrêmement ancien.
Le temps mis pour percevoir
au niveau cérébral une odeur
est de 25 millisecondes,
alors que pour percevoir une image,
il faut le double, 50 millisecondes.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que le bulbe olfactif, celui qui
va filtrer les odeurs, on en reparlera,
est situé juste derrière
les fosses nasales
et en contact direct
avec le cerveau des émotions.
Et ceci est bien fait
parce que c’est un sens très ancien,
hérité des petits primates qui nous ont
précédés il y a 80 millions d’années,
et qui se baladaient le nez par terre
à la quête de traces de nourriture.
Donc c’est resté
au fur et à mesure des âges.
Et même si chez l’homme,
la vision est plus utilisée que l’odorat,
l’odorat est très important
parce qu’il va être associé à la mémoire
extrêmement importante de notre vécu.
C'est ce que les spécialistes appellent
la mémoire autobiographique.
La mémoire des faits qui correspondent
à certains éléments de votre vécu,
notamment dans la petite enfance.
Tout le monde connaît et se souvient de
l'odeur du doudou que nous donnait Maman
et qui nous rappelait
le calme et la relaxation
en nous faisant évoquer
la mémoire de Maman près de nous.
Ça a été aussi très bien décrit
ensuite par la madeleine de Proust.
Le chemin des odeurs,
si on va plus en détail
dans le fonctionnement du cerveau,
il faut aller un peu plus loin.
On va essayer d’expliquer des
petits éléments de l’anatomie du cerveau.
Lorsque les odeurs sont perçues,
les cellules olfactives émettent,
bien sûr, un signal nerveux.
Ce signal nerveux est trié
au niveau du bulbe olfactif,
une petite région du cerveau
située derrière le nez,
et le bulbe olfactif envoie ces signaux
à un centre d’alerte dans le cerveau
qui s’appelle l’amygdale.
Rien à voir avec celle
que vous avez au fond de la bouche
ou que vous n’avez plus.
Et l’amygdale émet
une valence émotionnelle,
comme on a dit tout à l’heure,
c’est un centre d’alerte.
Elle dit que c’est neutre,
ça me fait plaisir
ou que j’ai envie de fuir,
ça sent mauvais.
Et ensuite, l’amygdale va interroger
le centre de la mémoire, l’hippocampe,
une petite région du cerveau, en disant :
« Tu connais cette odeur-là ?
- Oui, je connais.
Ça me fait très plaisir,
j’ai envie d’en humer davantage. »
Et puis ensuite, ce petit centre
de la mémoire, l’hippocampe,
va interroger le cerveau de la volonté,
le cerveau de la décision
qui est derrière le front,
ce qu’on appelle le préfrontal,
en lui disant :
« Que fais-tu de cette odeur ? »
Et le cerveau de la décision,
souvent, pas toujours,
comme on le verra,
va dire : « Ah oui, je veux, je fonce,
j’ai envie d’en consommer, d’en humer. »
Ou bien : « Ça sent mauvais,
Je fuis, je pars, je déteste. »
Au cours des pérégrinations de ces odeurs,
on s’aperçoit que l’ambiance
olfactive joue un rôle important.
Par exemple, je n'ai pas le moral.
« Ah, aujourd’hui, j’ai dû passer
un entretien d’embauche.
J’avais tout préparé,
j’étais content de moi,
Et je sors de là, je suis déçu.
Je passe devant la boulangerie,
assez favorite pour moi.
Il faisait chaud,
C'était ces jours derniers.
Il s’exhale une odeur de pain au chocolat.
Rien n'y fait, mais chakras sont fermés.
Plus loin, en rentrant chez moi,
je croise une femme
et d’un seul coup, je reconnais
son parfum, c’est Opium.
Oui, c’est le même que mettait ma copine
Amélie quand on sortait tous les deux.
Et je me souviens d’Amélie,
sa sérénité, sa joie de vivre,
son sourire.
Et tout de suite le moral me revient.
J’ai oublié mon entretien. »
La diffusion d’odeurs
peut donc modifier l’ambiance olfactive
et l’ambiance émotionnelle.
Tout le monde connaît ça.
Ça peut être, par exemple, la diffusion
d’odeurs de vanille dans les spas,
qui a un côté un peu relaxant,
la diffusion d’odeurs de citron
très souvent dans les salles de sport,
ça a un côté stimulant.
Ou la diffusion de cannelle
dans les établissements de coaching
ou les établissements bancaires,
pour donner un petit peu confiance.
Donc il y a une interprétation possible
en fonction en fonction
de ce type d’odeur.
Pour aller plus loin,
les chercheurs ont démontré -
Par exemple, on va prendre
l’expérience de William Overman,
qui était psychologue en Caroline du Nord,
et qui s’occupait d’étudiants
qui étudiaient les mathématiques.
Et il a eu l’idée de répartir deux groupes
d’étudiants dans deux salles en parallèle.
Dans une salle, au préalable,
il a diffusé une odeur d’indole,
qui n’est pas très sympa,
un peu repoussant comme odeur,
et dans l’autre salle, du jasmin.
Et il leur a fait résoudre la même
énigme, dans les deux salles.
Ceux qui étaient assis dans la salle
où était diffusée une odeur de jasmin
avaient un taux de réussite à l’énigme
qui était meilleur.
Autre exemple de cette influence
de l'ambiance olfactive.
Mais là, cette fois avec la sémantique,
on en reparlera tout à l’heure,
la signification des mots.
Je prends un petit flacon
d’acide isovalérique.
Je vous dirai à peu près
ensuite à quoi ça correspond.
Je le tends à une personne,
sous son nez, en disant :
« Tu trouves pas que ça sent le pied ? »
Et tout de suite, une émotion
extrêmement négative et repoussante
fait irruption dans le cerveau
de cette personne.
Et le même flacon d’acide isovalérique,
je le présente à une autre personne
à ma gauche et je lui dis :
« Ça sent le roquefort, non ? »
Et tout de suite, cette personne se voit
assise avec un énorme plateau de fromages
et elle a une émotion
beaucoup plus positive.
Or c’est vrai, vous pouvez vérifier,
l’acide isovalérique est bien produite
dans certains fromages,
notamment le roquefort,
et libérée aussi par la peau
de la plante des pieds.
Étonnant, non ?
Dernier exemple de l'influence
de cette ambiance olfactive.
Je prendrai l’exemple du clou de girofle.
Celles qui préparent le pain d’épice
utilisent un peu de clous
de girofle en cuisine.
Une émotion positive.
C’est sympa de préparer un petit
pain d’épices, pour le goûter.
Et puis, on repense à une autre
situation du clou de girofle,
c’est chez le dentiste.
Bon alors, maintenant il l’utilise peu.
Il utilise plutôt des gommes,
ou des pâtes à la menthe,
ou des dérivés du citron.
Mais autrefois, ils utilisaient
le clou de girofle
pour son petit côté anesthésiant.
On massait les gencives
avec cette pâte au clou de girofle
et ça sent très fort.
Et ça entraînait un stress car évidemment,
le patient attendait que la fraise arrive.
Donc vous voyez, les ambiances olfactives,
vraiment, vont contribuer à la façon
dont le cerveau va s’exprimer.
Et pour exprimer un peu la diversité
de ces bouquets d’odeurs,
on peut prendre aussi l’exemple
de la vanille où finalement,
à force d’apprendre la sémantique
correspondant aux notes,
correspondant aux odeurs,
aux notes des bouquets de parfums,
on va dire qu’il y aura des notes épicées,
fumées, boisées, cacaotées ou poudreuses,
comme Shalimar de Guerlain a su
très bien le transparaître dans un parfum.
Donc, finalement,
la diffusion d’odeurs,
l’ambiance olfactive,
c’est fondamental pour comprendre
le mécanisme.
Et au-delà de ça, il faut faire attention
que le cerveau ne se comporte pas toujours
On a vu tout à l’heure, je vous l’ai dit,
le cerveau de la décision,
normalement, c’est lui qui décide.
Eh bien, pas toujours.
Allez, on va prendre deux exemples.
C’est la fin de la matinée,
vous sortez du travail,
vous passez devant un foodtruck
qui exhale une odeur de bonne friture.
Immédiatement,
vous sentez le plaisir
vous inonder le corps
et vous vous précipitez pour acheter
votre cornet de frites.
Le cerveau de la volonté
n’a pas eu le temps de décider.
C’est le cerveau des émotions
qui vous contraint à consommer.
C’est ce que les neurologues
appelleront un effet bottom up.
C'est le bas du cerveau qui parle.
Et puis, deux jours plus tard,
vous vous levez le matin,
vous avez un peu trop regardé la télé
avec ces stupidités
du programme « Comme j’aime ».
D’accord ?
Vous vous dites : « Ce matin,
j’ai décidé de faire régime. »
Vous passez devant votre boulangerie,
toujours ce même parfum
de pain au chocolat ou d’éclair.
« Ah non, aujourd’hui je fais régime. »
Donc le cerveau de la volonté écrase
complètement la perception émotionnelle
liée à la détection des odeurs.
Donc le cerveau joue évidemment
un rôle important.
À partir de cette modulation
de l’émotion liée aux odeurs,
évidemment, le marketing s’en occupe,
c’est ce qu’on appelle
Vous me direz que maintenant,
avec les ventes sur Internet,
l’ordinateur, il ne va pas
exhaler des odeurs.
C’est vrai, c’est plus compliqué.
Mais quand vous vous rendez
bien sûr dans des magasins,
par exemple, des enseignes qui vont
vous vendre des boissons chaudes -
vous voyez ? -
une odeur de café,
une odeur de pain grillé.
Ou bien dans des enseignes
de grands magasins,
on s’arrangera pour
qu’il y ait une odeur de lavande,
une odeur de muguet, une odeur
de linge propre, au rayon lingerie,
une odeur de monoï ou de noix de coco
au rayon maillots de bain pour femmes.
Donc voilà, le marketing olfactif,
ça marche.
Ceux qui le pratiquent disent
que ça augmente
d’environ 30 % l’incitation à acheter,
puisque ça module des émotions,
ça entraîne donc une domination du cerveau
émotionnel sur celui de la volonté.
Donc, même si
vous n’avez pas envie d’acheter,
vous êtes incité un peu plus à acheter.
Voilà, on a vu que le cerveau
et les odeurs, ça se parle beaucoup,
ça bouge beaucoup,
ça dépend de notre environnement.
Et puis certains d’entre vous, sans doute,
ont eu l’idée quelques fois
de prendre des cours d’œnologie.
Ah ben oui, mais ce n’est pas facile
de nommer les notes florales,
les notes d’un bouquet d’un vin
avec des mots.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que le cerveau de la sémantique
a évolué beaucoup plus tardivement
que le cerveau olfactif.
Le cerveau olfactif, on l’a vu,
provient de l’héritage des primates,
puis ensuite des hominidés,
tandis que le cerveau des mots
est lié chez Sapiens,
avec le démarrage du langage articulé,
il y a à peu près 400 000 ans.
Donc, ces deux parties
du cerveau se parlent mal.
Donc, si vous voulez être
très fort en œnologie,
il faudra prendre des cours,
apprendre à mettre un mot sur une odeur.
Si vous associez une odeur à un mot,
vous arriverez beaucoup mieux
à mémoriser ce qui se passe.
C’est pareil avec ceux et celles
qui veulent être des experts
pour apprendre le nez à détecter
des parfums et ses différentes notes.
Là aussi, il faudra avoir un bagage
sémantique à côté de cela.
Pour terminer,
je dirais que, ici, ce soir,
on sent un certain nombre
d’odeurs, évidemment.
Et figurez-vous que certains parfumeurs
ont eu cette idée
de reproduire des odeurs
qu’on détecte dans les théâtres.
C’est notamment Olivia Giacometti,
une parfumeuse française très en vogue,
qui a créé des bougies Comédie-Française,
une bougie Coulisse aux notes de velours
poussiéreux, de fards et de poudre,
libérées par les comédiens
qui sont passés avant,
et une bougie Fauteuil de Molière
avec ses notes de cuir, de crin,
de bois de noyer et d’huile de lin.
Pour terminer,
je vous dirais de ne pas oublier que
le cerveau, magnifique chef d’orchestre,
est capable de marquer
un événement de votre vécu
par une émotion olfactive,
ce qui vous permet généralement
toute votre vie de vous en rappeler.
Génial, non ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)